-Thank you very much, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys, I hope everyone
had a good weekend.
I needed a break, so yesterday
I flew to Cancun and back.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, everyone is still talking
about this.
Following the backlash
over his trip to Cancun,
Senator Ted Cruz spent
the weekend trying his best
to help the people of Texas.
-Senator Ted Cruz
doing damage control
after his controversial trip
to Cancun last week.
-Cruz sharing these images
over the weekend,
loading water into Texans' cars,
many online critical
of the post.
-Yeah, people were upset
when they realized
Cruz was loading water
into his car.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna use this
to refill my waterbed."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it seemed like
an okay gesture until everyone
noticed the label on the bottles
said Ritz Carlton Cancun.
[ Laughter ]
A little souvenir.
Actually,
Cruz wanted to do more,
but he had a parasailing lesson
at 3:00, so he --
People were also upset that Cruz
tweeted those pictures himself.
Even white people
who only posted black squares
on Instagram were like,
"You gotta do more than that."
[ Laughter ]
Ted Cruz is like the friend
who offers to help you move,
but every time you see him,
he's just carrying
the same box of pillows.
It's like, "I have to take this
call. Can you get the table?
Hello. Yeah. Yeah, just get
the heavy things."
Yep, the photo-op
didn't work out too well.
Most people just drove away
when he tried showing them
his vacation photos.
He's like,
"You ever think you can get
behind the bar
at a Senior Frog's?"
[ Laughter ]
But Cruz tried to be helpful
in other ways.
Later, he showed Texans
how to make frozen margs
with the snow
in their living rooms.
[ Audience oohs ]
Seriously, you know Cruz
is having a rough 2021
when fueling a riot
at the Capitol is
nowhere near
his biggest problem.
[ Laughter ]
Things are so bad for Cruz,
he spent today thinking about
the good ol' days
when people just thought
he was the Zodiac Killer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, we're in a pandemic.
Shaking hands, handing out
water, serving food.
Right now, a Carnival cruise
is safer than a Ted Cruz.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Cruz is trying
to redeem himself
after his Mexico trip,
but I don't think it's working.
Check out what fellow Texans
sent to his house yesterday.
This is real.
♪♪
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's real.
In honor of Cruz, they played
that mariachi classic,
"El Baggo de Douche."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Cruz was like,
"Play as loud as you want.
I'm in Tijuana."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
I saw that Disney+ has added
a warning to a show
that you might not expect.
Watch this.
-The return of the iconic
"Muppet Show,"
now coming with
a serious new warning --
a content disclaimer at
the beginning of 18 episodes,
warning viewers of the program's
"negative depictions
and/or mistreatment
of people or cultures."
-Yeah, and just to be safe,
Gonzo's nose
will also be blurred.
[ Laughter ]
I think they made
the right move.
In one episode, Fozzie
does a stand-up routine
that begins with,
"hickory, dickory, dock."
[ Laughter ]
Here's some big music news.
After 28 years together,
Daft Punk is splitting up.
I'm gonna be honest,
they picked a pretty weird time
to stop wearing their masks.
[ Laughter ]
One of the guy's friends
was like, "Don't worry.
You'll find another mute,
helmet-wearing synth-pop artist
who pretends he's a robot
that you can start a band with."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this.
I saw that a 18-karat-gold
PlayStation 5 is on sale
for half a million dollars.
Here's a photo. Look at this.
Wow. Yeah.
Apparently, one of these
shows up in the new movie
"Scarface: The Tween Years."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, while most of the
country waits to get vaccinated,
two women in Florida were caught
trying to cut the line
in a pretty strange way.
Watch this.
-The Florida Department
of Health says
two women dressed up
as "grannies"
to try and get a second
coronavirus vaccine this week.
The sheriff's office says the
women were 44 and 34 years old,
apparently wearing bonnets,
gloves, and glasses
when they went to the
Orange County Convention Center.
[ Laughter ]
-The nurse was like, "Names?"
And they were like,
"Uh, Grace and Frankie?"
[ Laughter ]
Officials got suspicious when
the women didn't call six times
to confirm the appointment.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, the women gave
themselves away
when they seemed unfamiliar with
CBS's prime-time lineup.
[ Laughter ]
In Florida, the only way
to prove that you're a senior
is if you have a lower back
tattoo of Andy Williams.
Wait, that's not true.
Are you sure?
And finally, this is strange.
I saw that federal agents
in Ohio just made
a pretty, pretty surprising
discovery. Check this out.
-Customs agents in Cincinnati
found something stronger
than sugar on
a shipment of Corn Flakes.
The cereal was topped with
44 pounds of cocaine
worth nearly $3 million.
-It's serious.
The suspects are expected to
receive a sentence of 20 years
to cinnamon life in prison.
[ Laughter ]
I think the whole incident
explains why
the Corn Flakes mascot
went from a rooster to this.
[ Rooster crowing ]
[ Laughter ]